so here we are the end of the first week
of the cop in Paris we had the heads of
state arrive on Monday there was a
hurricane of activity announcements it's
a very different cop than than in years
past in Copenhagen 60 years ago the
leaders came at the very end and it was
kind of up to them to seal the deal here
it was up to them to open the day we've
seen a lot of activity outside
negotiations we've had more than 20
governments come together and commit to
Dublin R&D funding for clean energy
technologies and that happened in
concert with with the coalition of major
investors we also saw Indian France come
together on a major solar Alliance
that's generated a lot of excitement we
saw big announcement from a coalition of
governments to invest five billion
dollars in protecting tropical forests
there was a lot of excitement early on
there was a little bit of worrying you
know once the presents left on Wednesday
but here we are and everybody seems
remarkably calm at peace pretty
confident that things are gonna work out
next video there's no doubt that that
some big debates are gonna come out
we're gonna see some explosions we're
gonna see some drama but so far
everybody seems to think that we're
gonna get a deal the question is how
detailed it will be there are still
questions about how strong it will be
but there's not a lot of doubt right now
that the government is going to come
together and sign an agreement at the
end of next week